[Musique]
matthias langhoff champion du monde
d'homophobie allez vas-y lâche moi que
tu paies des toits il a donc été décidé
de conditionner la participation de
matthias langhoff aux prochains
championnats du monde à une mission au
sein d'une association sportive
homosexuel avant de les conduire en
croatie ok fixe
c'est quoi la meilleure façon de faire
un pressing nettoyage à sec
pourquoi vous mettez votre but à leur
promettons si vous en avez rien à [ __ ]
de rien en fait alors si vous supportez
plus on n'est pas obligé d'y aller
d'accord les gay games est pas qu une
énorme fête c'est aussi le moment où on
peut montrer au monde qu'on est
solidaire et qu'on existe une belle
bande de mecs qui traverse la moitié de
l'europe en bus c'est sûr il va se
passer des trucs j'ai une règle dans
l'équipe pas de l'oeuvre est entré
crevettes
construit en maquillant quoi la chance
d'être payés
sinon vous avez trouvé ça commence pour
la crevette le meilleur c'est là que
puis avec des paillettes c'est encore
mieux excusez-moi cci-ci et
l'association homosexuelle pour
l'intégration la tolérance et le respect
dans le water polo ensemble albums de bd
je sais pas maintenant
vous le reconnaissez pas matthias
langhoff champion du monde d'homophobie
allez vas-y lâche moins cupide et ouaret
la caméra ce qui l'attend qu'était
décidé de conditionner la participation
de matthias langhoff aux prochains
championnats du monde à une mission
d'intérêt général au sein d'une
association sportive homosexuels droit
il aura la responsabilité d'entraîner
pendant trois mois d'aller vers 200 m en
retrait au pédalage vous calmer la
[ __ ] avant de les conduire en croatie
comme géo en moins chiant avec les beaux
mecs
ah les entraînements surprise olé c'est
quoi la meilleure façon de faire un
pressing fred de nettoyage à sec en
lesbienne yens
et [ __ ] mais je comprends plus rien on
a le droit de dire des trucs comme ça
oui mais toi non les amis qui j'en ai
plein ce sont des gens brillants
extrêmement rapide pourquoi vous mettez
vos buts allaient vite promettant c'est
ton et qu'elle vous en avez rien à
[ __ ] de rien en fait
alors si vous supportez plus on n'est
pas obligé d'y aller d'accord aussi tu
voulais les abandonner même ta propre
fille bien trouvera plus de voir les
games s'est pas d'une énorme fête c'est
aussi le moment où on peut montrer au
monde qu'on est solidaire et qu'on
existe moi j'ai pas le temps pour ce
cirque
la sanction d'un tiers une belle bande
de mecs qui traverse la moitié de
l'europe en bus c'est sûr il va se
passer des trucs
il ya une règle dans l'équipe pas de
l'oeuvre est entre une crevette
[Applaudissements]
oui
deux cas
[Applaudissements]
quand je pense qu'il y en a qui n'ont
pas la chance d'espérer
ils n'ont vous avez trouvé ça commence
dans la crevette le meilleur c'est
l'accueil fut avec des paillettes
s'entend bien
[Musique]